yeah you want that balance right yeah i
had an opener once to say to me and this
is the last time i used him i'm not
going to say his name because he's going
to get really mad because i've said his
name before by telling the story yeah
but he said he's opener right yeah what
would you do you're headlining yeah you
bring a feature
he gets off stage the host goes up to
bring you up and as you pass
he goes
follow that
did he make you smell his fingers too
that would have me
yeah yeah i thought it was gonna be way
worse you're like he raped the weight
yeah
no yeah you follow that yeah that's i
mean
but it's it's but because i'll tell you
why that disturbs me yeah it's because
already then you know to him it's some
sort of weird competition
right and it's also i'm
you're opening for me it just seems
is it me i know i have an issue with
like the opening act to try who's like
their mission is not to kill but to blow
you out of the water yeah because then
it's you're right it's not about them
it's about you yeah and it's i think you
get to a point like i think most comics
when they're opening for too long they
get to a point where they're like i'm
gonna [ __ ] make it a point and it's
like well then you should be headlining
you shouldn't be yeah featuring i had a
[ __ ] like a local mc come up to me in
texas and go i'm usually a headliner but
and i wanted to go well then go home
because
you're hosting i've had that happen a
lot it's weird they say that to you yeah
well they'd be like yeah i'm just my off
week i decided to just you know yeah and
you're kind of like you don't have to
have a disclaimer man i don't give a
[ __ ] just go up and kill
yeah and it's also like
i've opened for dudes like i mean i want
to brag but
martin lawrence
right and he told me do five now could i
do longer than five yeah right yeah
right but it's like i'm just gonna do
what i do
and i'm there to serve him
yeah right and i and i know that he's a
gigantic star
right and that's i'm just blessed to be
here but some comics have this like
especially it must be rough you're
you're you live in the midwest you've
been doing comedy for 15 years
right no breaks
yeah but you're not making them live in
the midwest move that's true yeah i
didn't tell you to live in toledo ohio
pack a bag and get [ __ ] getting
why do you think people don't do it
move
fear fear fear but also like
i think there's a comfort in being a
bigger fish in a small pond and then
i've seen great comics move to new york
and it's tough and they're great so it
just being funny is no guarantee that
things are going to be easy yeah do you
want to be a star in a d3 school or do
you want to be
you know the eighth fastest in a d1
school right good point that's true i i
think the second
me too yeah yeah i think the second yeah
i mean i remember
it's
were you good when you moved to new york
did you start in new york i grew up in
new york so i uh i it's weird the thing
about growing up there and starting
there is that people see you when you
suck i was 19 so wow i mean people saw
me at my worst and it's it's weird when
you're doing jokes that are like kind of
what you think are like oh there's kind
of a dark premise and you're bombing
with it
people they just not only don't like
your comedy they're like you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know
so yeah yeah so it's tough to
to like well here's all the worst of me
yeah and this is where i'm just gonna be
but that could also be your perception
of what you're going through
because i think that like
even when i was like young
and in 95 is when i started and i would
say god i don't know how to
write a structured joke i'm just kind of
crazy up there and doing weird things
and maybe some comics were like you know
what do you what the [ __ ] you doing
there up there it's you don't know how
to write a joke but there were certain
comics like
paulie
saw me as an open micro and he came up
to me
back then and he goes
you don't know how to write a joke but
there's just something weird about you
that's interesting which is the kind of
feedback that i like
it's like oh well then oh he saw you
yeah he like saw who you he's like oh
you see something unique in me that's
cool yeah yeah and that and that's for
me what
is cool about
comedy right so in when you were coming
up i'm sure like because if i'm seeing
an open mic or
say something dark and they're
committing to it and it's not working i
don't think
what an [ __ ] i think
it's hard
the [ __ ] thing well joey think jokes
are hard at open mics i feel like when
something isn't obvious with an audience
there's like a deal where you're like i
pause you know that's the joke you laugh
at an open mic they're like we know what
you're doing [ __ ] we know your
tricks we don't give a [ __ ] all right i
mean i remember a good friend of mine
gary veeder he's got great jokes but he
i remember watching him just bomb at
mike's because they were just like
obvious not the premises the premier the
jokes are great yeah but they're just
like we we see the mechanics ah
it's so it's hard to do bits at uh and
mike's yeah
it's such a it just brings me back to
how
do you ever think
how the [ __ ] did i
go through that
i don't know if i could do it again i
don't either just because the the mics
suck i would hand out flyers instead
because i would just rather
do the handing out flyers and be like
why don't these people i don't know i
felt more freedom to fail if they were
just strangers although the looks you
would get handing out flyers on the
street were just
the pity was just brutal i remember a
woman just looked at me and she was like
oh
just call me a [ __ ] loser don't you
yeah don't don't go oh yeah i was a
flyer giver outer i hated in high school
was my first american job i was very
proud
for la fitness i did as a summer job too
for comedy clubs and then i was like
this is depressing well would you have
to i mean did you have to hand out the
flowers for you to perform yeah oh my
god yeah and i remember like there were
different places you learned how to work
different streets like i do upper west
side like 109th street
and
that was hard because no one was there
you're literally like you see a person
like a block away or like hopefully i
get that
yeah yeah you would literally go on
stage where there would be like four
people in the crowd and you have to be
like hot line up tonight this person's
here this person's here and then they'd
be in the crowd them and like four other
people and they'd be like your first
comic and it would be me and
you [ __ ]
you lied to me yeah yeah no but
if you like a
when you're passing out flyers
is there a chance you you're not going
to perform because you didn't pass
enough flyers out yeah i saw this good
friend of mine dan st jermaine uh he did
it once
and you had to do it two hours it's the
first time i met him probably like 14
years ago or something and he's handing
out the flyers then he goes yeah i think
i'm good and the guy goes you only have
to do 10 more minutes you can go on he
goes nah nah i think i think i got i'm
good and i was like i've never seen a
human being put themselves through that
for nothing i was
like you bring yourself to an hour 50
minutes for no money for no stage time
yeah he was just like i can't i can't do
this wow
i in la we're not we do bringer rooms
here well you can't fly here in l.a
there's no yeah yeah there's not enough
foot traffic oh yeah
in new york times square was not as bad
to bark there because uh
there were so many people that would go
by more quickly what are these easier
though is because bringer rooms in la
are like you can't perform unless you
bring 30 people
30 i mean that's well you run out of
friends quickly i had friends who were
like i'd be like coming to my show and
they're like i'm not watching all those
shitty they were fine watching you bomb
but like the other lunatic
the three of them are like [ __ ]
mental patients that are never gonna do
it again yeah and the problem with open
mics is too is because you're mixed in
with the crazies and the homeless
sometimes like when i started open mics
in la in 97 or 98 when i moved here
there was half of them were homeless
right people just treat people i would
love to see that show i know but that's
what you think but then they go on and
it's like nonsense and you're like i
don't want to follow i don't want to
live in this like
it becomes craziness i'm with you you
have a guy like robert william apravia
and he still does him he's in a green
suit yeah
and the sun and the sun
the audience is like
five minutes of this yeah oh no you lose
it's like i had no problem i mean you're
like i can handle bombing but they'd be
reading the open mic sheet like all
right your next comic btk serial killer
it would be like and then you're like i
have to sit through this [ __ ] yeah wait
speaking of btk serial killer please
pull up his a sketch of um the sketch of
him what is it called really btk um
sketch of btk fine torture whatever
did you get this cookie
yeah these are the best cookies
you've really had this before yeah i
want you to tell me who you think
this is a sketch of the real btk killer
yeah
damn
holy [ __ ]